hello my name is Olivia Lan and I am a researcher and an educator at IBM Quantum this video marks the launch of a
brand new series on the kkit YouTube channel and our learning platform called Quantum Computing in
practice in short in this series I'm going to show you how to use a quantum computer that exists right now to its
full potential there are billions of videos already on the internet about quantum computers and their future potential or on theoretical Concepts
behind Quantum computation which are also just as important see understanding Quantum information and computation
hosted by John watus for example but in this course we are going to assume the learner maybe knows a little bit more
than we have in the past and we will go very far technically speaking and that's because over the past year and at the
time of this recording it is 2024 we have seen a shift a phase transition if you will into a new era of
computation quantum computers are finally approaching the point where they can be useful even though experimenting with
smallscale circuits and quantum computers was necessary to educate our community on how to utilize these machines no one was running experiments
that couldn't also be performed on regular old classical computers but as of today we have entered an era of
quantum utility and what is utility you might ask it is different than Quantum Advantage which can be understood at the
point at which quantum computers are outperforming classical computers at a meaningful task in instead utility means
that they can start to compete with one another and this is the natural next step in the technological
Evolution IBM published a paper that showed for the first time last year a quantum computer could be used to
simulate a physical model and compete with state-of-the-art classical simulation techniques it even bested the
Brute Force attempts and let researchers have a new Avenue that they can use for research so why is this all happening
now well in the past few months IBM has made Quantum processors of over 100 cubits widely available if you're
already a user you might have noticed that we took down a lot of our smaller processors to make way for these larger chips and we felt like it was really
important to do so because some numbers of cubits can still be simulated classically without a problem so there's
no real advantage that can be gained by using these chips however at 100 cubits this is no longer the case they cannot
be simulated classically it is also important to note that there are these things called simulators which
are essentially computer programs and they can mimic some behavior of quantum systems including noise however please
don't miss the fact that I said mimic simulators are not quantum computers they cannot produce the results that
quantum computers can at this scale but they are still an important part of our testing workflow so that was a very
lengthy answer to the question at the top of this slide what is practical Quant Quantum Computing in this course I'm going to teach you about realistic
potential use cases for Quantum and the best practices for running and experimenting on these larger scale
processors today so who is this course aimed at let's begin by doing some level setting
at the beginning this course is for everyone that aims to develop new applications for quantum computers wants
to know how to scale up their current work or learn how to use quantum in their existing workflows I previously
mentioned that this course will be very Hands-On and we won't be discussing theoretical aspects nearly as much we
expect you to come in with a basic understanding of what Quantum computation is but if you're not quite there yet no worries please just watch
the first few episodes of John waters's course and you'll be ready we also want to make sure that folks watching know
that this isn't just a course for physicists or even computer scientists these two subjects have really been
hogging Quantum Computing for the past decade or so we want to make sure that others who work with big data or
simulations such as Engineers chemists and material scientists know that this course is also for them in summary this
course is directed towards a broad audience and we hope that you'll join us for its entirety upon completing this course you
will be able to understand how to create and run a utility scale job through kuit runtime including the entire workflow
you will be able to understand the main types of error mitigation and also understand likely application areas in the short term you will also be able to
per all of these algorithms in kit and lastly we expect you to be able to understand noise and how to deal with it
so let's get started Quantum Computing is an exciting new technology in an early stage of development but it's just
one chapter in the story of computation which goes back thousands of years I think it's important to understand this
context because it makes what we're aiming to do here a little bit more intuitive predictable and less
sci-fi since ancient times we as humans have needed to perform computations or
in other words process information according to certain rules and constraints in order to enable
communication construction Commerce science and all other aspects of Our Lives we've looked to the physical world
for assistance and through ingenious discoveries we've constructed devices to help us compute long ago devices were
made from wood bone knotted ropes and they stored information and facilitated calculations much differently than we do
today Mechanical Devices built from levers gears and other Machinery advance from early astronomical clocks to
calculators to sophisticated Computing devices such as differential analyzers that solved equations using wheels and
rotating discs even the technology of writing has played an important part in the story by allowing people to perform
computation that they wouldn't be able to otherwise when we think about computers today we tend to think about
electronic digital computers but this is actually a fairly recent technology electronic digital computers
were first built in the 1940s the earliest known tool actually for computation is the Sumerian Abacus
which experts think was invented in Babylon in 27 to 2300 BC that's a really
long time ago but we have come to understand more and more about the natural world from Archimedes to uid to
Einstein our needs for more computational resources has exploded today we have supercomputers which are
basically many very powerful computers hooked up in parallel they are one of the best tools that mankind has for
solving difficult problems but there are still plenty of problems that even these behem of computers will never be able to
solve more on this later so we've established that humans have been using physics and nature to help us compute
for thousands of years and to help us with our NeverEnding quest to compute more and bigger things you might already